boa noite como todo mundo sabe as
eleições se aproximando e estamos
lançando é na candidatura esse ano para
tabela é a cidade de vocês não me abati
nenhum nesse amplo e eu já tocou com o
que vem acontecendo ao longo dos anos e
hoje em dia a pessoa pode estar na final
ela vai estar na política ela vai roubar
aqui os política corrupta que se está
aqui no gente é essa a vot mesmo é você
comprou a foto é claro entendo uma coisa
que eu estou comprando é que tem gente
que vem chega na europa que tudo bem tá
boa
que beleza zb e três quintos de votos é
um quilo e meio de votos moído e chegar
à padaria ou para viver bem feijó com
nossa filha e dois mato grossos que você
está vendendo beleza cumpriu voto no
outro ano mas é a pessoa mas é porque a
minha rua da sé a falta mas é que a
minha rua não tem iluminação chegado
[Risadas]
quando o nome de deus não penso em sair
é o cara troca o voto em bloco a
construir a casa e encontrou a casa lá a
casa feita mas não tem a rua para chegar
na casa porque quer burro aqui no brasil
político empréstimo lugarzinho político
é muita corrupção
eu queria morar no estádio engenheiro e
pelos estados unidos foi vai gravar nos
estados unidos mas eu não tenho dinheiro
para os estados unidos é muito fácil eu
espero uma carta do grupo de volta para
minha terra o google precisa voltar para
minha terra não tenho dinheiro eu moro
nos estados unidos pronta assim a onde é
sua casa onde estava não vai me deixar
no óleo no meio do ano e meio não mas a
gente tem que deixar você na sua casa na
paz eu sei onde a minha casa me deixando
mendonça própria sobre o problema é
porque no brasil diz político é tudo
corrupto que no brasil diz político é
tudo corrupção e tu sabe o que é
corrupção desgraça a apae é porque vai
ter uma gincana na escola eu preciso
comprar o uso da gincana
a luz 20 reais e fala que eu pague sim
na verdade abusa 20 você ficou com 15
rafael quer fazer um trabalho da escola
eu tenho que comprar um isopor com
hotéis o promef é r$5 o apoiador reais e
ficou com três sabem sair corrupção e
desvio de verbas
você acha que de corrupção é de virar
guia da menina também aí a pessoa falar
de pequena corrupção pegando dinheiro do
pai bicho estava no sol todo dia um
bichinho meu deu e e um chupa chupa
chupa dinheiro vai reclamar que rouba o
dinheiro da menina tomava o hamas é que
eu só fazia isso na escola chegado
comércio na escola nessa equipe que em
você acha que eu entrei na política
dormir ou de acordar e ter fim
boa conversa serviço feito na escola
então antes que você fala na minha bunda
eu converso com o velho ponte ponte em
mundo quer fazer uma coisa boa tem que
ajudar a bolívia tenta cantar você tiver
no facebook e clique em compartilhar
compartilhar não se fosse uma foto assim
se você ama satanás sol e se você ama
jesus compartilha a gestão compartilhada
no rio chegou no céu o projeto tudo bem
vai passar a concentrar pra eu ver que
meus arquivos que você tá muito pra
filha bateu na mãe os pela cada mulher
compartilham minha foto em trair chegada
e assinamos não compartilha esse vídeo
que você está aqui no youtube e marca
como fez e marcando gols e cada marcada
com gostei mão desse tamanho cumprir com
o meu nome é vote nesse ano e nesse ano
dotti negro essa desgraça não aguento
mais a street
anne no meu caso só se hoje viu